[Musique]
nous sommes au début mais jim bryson a
quelque chose à nous montrer
sur ces petites sert bien à l'abri
pouces ce qu'il appelle ses bébés
chaque ministère se cache un plan de
citrouilles que jim va bichonner pendant
des mois car c'est un amateur de
concours de citrouilles géantes jour mon
cousin m'a offert un blanc qui a produit
une citrouille de près de 300 kg
chaque année depuis jeudi que je vais
arrêter mais quand le printemps arrive
c'est plus fort que moi
agriculteur retraité il a travaillé
toute sa vie de manière conventionnelle
il labourer la terre et utiliser des
engrais chimiques et des pesticides et
c'est d'abord de cette manière qu'il
fait pousser ses citrouilles
2011 j'ai établi le record du monde avec
une citrouille de 850 kg je comprenais
rien au sol et c'était de la chance plus
qu'autre chose
il a toutefois l'impression de plafonner
son sol s'épuise et pour grossir ses
citrouilles ont besoin de toujours plus
d'engrais c'est alors qu'un déclic se
produit
suis mis à faire des cultures de
couverture s'est amélioré mon sol de
manière incroyable tous les
micro-organismes et qu'il y ait dans le
sol ça rend les planteurs russe
des cultures de couverture comme ce
segment bien vivant dans lequel jim à
implanter ses citrouilles cette année à
toute petite échelle jim nourrit donc
son sol avec du fumier et des plantes
ça peut paraître banal mais c'est une
petite révolution
[Musique]
nous retrouvons jim bryson au mois de
juin depuis notre dernière visite les
plantes citrouilles ont pris de
l'ampleur
cette vigne va pousser de 20-25 cm par
jour
les fleurs seront bientôt polliniser
celle veut espérer battre le record de
la plus grosse citrouille jim bryson
doit traiter son sol aux petits oignons
et pour éviter de l'épuiser il fait des
rotations
voici l'une des parcelles qui
accueillera les citrouilles de 2022
l'automne dernier dumas plantés ici du
seigle et de la vsv lui ces plantes ont
survécu à l'hiver et sont repartis de
plus belle au printemps
en s'associant avec les bactéries du sol
la vis comme tout les légumineuses
arrive à capter la sorte de l'air cet
azote sera ensuite disponible pour
fertiliser les citrouilles le seigle qui
produit une masse racinaire
impressionnante contribue quant à lui à
améliorer la structure du sol
et comme il faut de la variété même
quand on nourrit des micro organismes et
des vers de terre jim saupoudre ces
plantes de feuilles mortes
et la saison ensuite le tout d'un
mélange de 12 grain différentes et puis
il brasse
[Musique]
il faudra être un pote avant tout couper
je sème les graines de la prochaine
crise tueur
dans dix jours elles auront germé
il ya toujours quelque chose qui pousse
c'est comme dans la nature on ne voit
jamais une terre où il ne pousse rien
[Musique]
toujours des plantes de la clé pour
bâtir le seul
pendant l'été jim coup prend ainsi trois
fois sont couverts pour maximiser la
fertilité de sa terre et à sa grande
surprise sans aucun labour les petites
graines déposé à la surface finissent
toujours par germer malgré l'épaisse
couche de 2,6 g de feuilles ça fait cinq
ans que je fais ça et à chaque fois je
me dis que ça ne marchera pas mais ça
fonctionne toujours je n'ai pas labourer
depuis jeunes charrues flambant neuf
mais je pense que je ne l'utiliserai
jamais
cette façon de faire a complètement
changé l'alluré du sol la fille de jim
quel psy qui partage aussi sa passion
pour les citrouilles géantes s'étonne de
la différence
quand j'étais jeune pékin ont tourné le
sol tu pouvais voir la terre était pas
fertile comme elle est aujourd'hui il y
avait
et moins vers de terre il y avait moins
de biodiversité dans les sols
[Musique]
auparavant on croyait que la terre
idéale était formé de grains fins comme
du sel maintenant on sait qu'une terre
en santé et plein d'agrégats
le mot à retenir ici c'est biodiversité
mais septembre chez jim et qu'elle s'y
bryson c'est le sprint final dans la
course à la plus grosse citrouille
[Musique]
il pulvérise débit aux stimulants à base
de plantes sur les feuilles
[Musique]
bien dissimulée sous de multiples
couverture un énorme fruits oranges
trône désormais au milieu du jardin
[Musique]
la culture des citrouilles est
extrêmement gourmandes en ont mêlé
bryson remarque que depuis qu'il
s'inspire de l'agroécologie beaucoup de
choses ont changé
seul n'est plus le même il ya toute une
vie de da
nous devons un rosé beaucoup moins
maintenant
on utilisait sans galindo par plate par
journée maintenant on utilise 50 gallons
par semaine pour trois plantes alors
n'utilise vraiment - laufon l'utiliser à
voir mais est ce que tous ces
changements seront suffisants pour
obtenir une citrouille gagnante cette
année entre père et fille les avis sont
partagés
les ses traits qu'on a maintenant on
veut qu'ils soient au moins 2000 et
offrir
500 vols
[Musique]
et bien c'est qu'elle s'y qui avait
raison en octobre les bryson ont
fracassé le record de la plus grosse
citrouille au canada en franchissant
pour la première fois la barre des 2000
livres c'est plus de 900 kg tout ça sans
avoir recours aux engrais chimiques